the book I've written a p of the Jungle
is trying to be very practical manual
and I go through this in detail and one
of the things I've done there which a
lot of people have got back to me so I'm
glad I put it in was whenever something
goes wrong it's not what you want or
it's not what you expect the chimp kicks
and you get emotional reaction I say
immediately program yourself to say okay
I've now got an emotional message what's
the plan because that what's the plan
from the computer flicks you into human
mode nice and everybody says so powerful
that's good something happens I go okay
what's the plan and immediately I know
because you've shifted system there's a
calmness starts coming because the
chimp's going okay I don't have to worry
now i' I've alerted and you're on the
bow now you're coming up with a plan so
it's something as simple as that that
you have to learn every time I get
emotional stop and say okay what's the
plan being emotional isn't going to help
so that's the kind of stuff which it may
not resonate with everyone and I've
tried to put a lot in the book that
people in the past when I've what that
resonates with me yeah you
know that's really good what's the plan
because I guess the chimp is the the
warning system but it's not the planning
system plan system exactly and people
engage with the emotion I keep saying
that's not what it's there for yeah so
if you get anxious go thank you thank
the chimp you've got me anxious let me
work the plan out let's get a solution
let's see what it is and sometimes the
plan may not solve the solution so let's
I'll go back to relationships cuz it's
big one in most people's lives and let's
say that the relationship's going wrong
and there something you don't want to go
wrong and you get very emotional as this
person says look I'm sorry but I think
this is the end of the line um and your
emotions go and you say what's the plan
and you think well there isn't a plan
because it is the end of the line well
there is a plan the plan is to say for
example it may not resonate with
everyone this happens to lots of people
we do get over it yes we could even be
emotionally scarred but Life Will Go On
nearly everybody finds somebody else if
that's what you want yeah and life will
continue if you have that in your head
and say it will take around 3 months on
average you'll go through a lot of
emotions but you will come out the other
side so take a deep breath you've got
three months of a rot and Tumble coming
for someone to have that as the plan
yeah is a good plan because you're
saying I'm accepting it's got to I've
got to go through
it so taking a much more dramatic
example which and everyone's different
in what how they approach it my Approach
uh as said Psychiatry is not happy world
so I deal with unfortunately time time
parents who've lost a child they died in
the sleep or an accident and this is
tragic I cannot change that and they
can't change we all know that uh and
then to say what's the plan would be a
little bit unkind y instead you got to
work through but I'd explain we we're
going to go through grief not everyone
would agree with me I say to them you
won't recover I don't think you recover
uh and you won't even come to terms with
it what you'll do is you'll manage the
system but you'll have some good days in
the future and you'll have some terrible
days we're going to learn how to manage
them and things will will get better but
you will be scarred and I found that's
really helpful to people because it's
reality yeah so there you've got what's
the plan but it's done in a much gentler
way because obviously you can imagine
emotional distress is just incredibly
painful then it doesn't set up like a
false expectation or a hope in their
mind of like they're going to be
completely back to normal yeah and so
just saying that that's never going to
happen but let's figure out a way to
manage this yeah and to the less of
though obviously really painful extend a
broken relationship yeah that can be a
loss of a job it can be where you didn't
want to leave a job but there's a bully
in the company or you just can't
tolerate it anymore and you've go
through a grief reaction you think this
your identity might go uh there's a lot
of areas where I'd give a lot of TLC but
also you know a little bit of like come
on we still need a plan but that plan
can be that how do I deal with the
feelings of loss how do I deal with the
really bad emotions I'm
experiencing it doesn't mean let's be
positive I'm not a keen fan of that if
I'm honest I'm a keen fan of let's let's
use reality and reality can be positive
but I'm also reality is sometimes you
can't be positive there is a negative
yeah there's nothing good about
something which you know is a
Devastation to you I don't think that's
helpful to say that yeah I think the
answer is sometimes we get scarred hey
friends thank you so much for watching
if you enjoyed this clip then click here
for the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day bye-bye